Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
This is going to be my Arrow Episode 7 video.
I’ve also got some new Black Canary pictures
of Laurel in her costume and details on the
Crossover Episode.
So let’s talk some Cupid First, who you
may remember as a young mary winchester on
supernatural.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up.
Starting with Top 5 moments from the episode.
Number 5 - Flashback Cupid Origin Story
I think the reason they teased Cupid in the
last episode was because they wanted to open
with a flashback and didn’t want to have
to add another scene explaining who she was.
I’m a big fan of this, it means we can just
get right into the action at the beginning
of episodes.
Her origin story on the show is really close
to the one in the comics.
Oliver saves her life and she develops an
obsession for him.
In the comics she was special forces and went
through an experiment that made her super
strong.
On the show they made her a former police
officer with no special powers.
The police training was the reason she had
a background in fighting but in the time since
the season 2 finale when she picked up that
Arrow she’d been doing extra training.
So that’s why she was able to trade punches
with Oliver.
Number 4 - Team Arrow versus Team Cupid
Wasn’t it creepy how Cupid and her CI were
like a bizzaro version of Oliver and Felicity.
Looks like them having sex didn’t end well.
Be forewarned Olicity shippers.
Their team Cupid scene was pointed at you.
The Oliver explanation about being alone was
totally a manufactured ‘Felicity Moment’
but I thought it worked.
She and Oliver are slowly coming to terms
with the reality of their relationship and
what they can and can’t do.
They haven’t really dealt with it since
episode 1.
The Cupid Fight scene was pretty amazing.
Arrow always has the best fight choreography
so that’s no surprise.
Favorite stunt was when cupid kicked the grate
loose and they dropped down.
Oliver had to dislocate his own thumb to get
loose from the cuffs.
Everytime I see a character do that I wince.
Vin Diesel popped both of his shoulders out
of their sockets during Pitch Black.
Cupid the character is coming back later this
season.
They explained she’s joining the Suicide
Squad, and replacing Harley Quinn.
That was a nice easter egg.
I think the reason they did that was because
now that they’re making the suicide squad
movie.
They don’t want to add confusion by doing
Harley Quinn on Arrow.
Which kind of sucks.
Number 3 - Oliver and Katana Team Up
We finally get to see Katana in action and
get some backstory.
Her explanation fits with the comics.
She didn’t go into really great detail but
I expect the show to dedicate an episode to
that later this season.
Explain who Maseo and Katana were running
from.
In the comics she doesn’t actually become
Katana till after something really crazy happens.
And I don’t think Arrow would have cast
that character if they didn’t intend to
do that.
Long story short, she’s a verified badass
with a sword.
Expect her to fight other characters who wield
swords.
Hmmm, didn’t we see a couple of characters
using swords earlier this season…
I think as she and oliver came back to their
apartment they bonded.
So consider them friends now.
Number 2 - Ray Palmer and Felicity
This is probably agony for Olicity shippers
but let’s be real.
Ray Palmer isn’t doing anything wrong, he’s
not a bad character but he does have an agenda
he’s not telling everyone about.
I love how Felicity gets that princess moment.
That look on her face when she got those diamonds
is like the look on Roy’s Face when Oliver
gave him his costume.
We can all laugh about that for a sec.
Points of interest.
The whole subplot about the land ray palmer
is trying to get for the co-generation total
red herring.
It contains Dwarf Star Alloy he’s going
to use to make his super suit.
Then there’s his Iron Man Suit.
It’s called an A.T.O.M.
exoskeleton.
So at some point they’ll explain what the
acronym stands for.
But if you listen carefully you can here a
new music cue playing.
That’s going to be his Atom Theme.
Like Oliver has an Arrow theme, Barry Allen
has a Flash theme.
His theme music sounded like it had a few
cues from the John Williams superman theme
too.
It’s just a coincidence that Ray Palmer’s
colors are the same as Superman’s Colors.
But I like the imagery here.
This is really early for them to be teasing
it, so we could get a glimpse of it in the
mid-season finale.
and my Number 1 moment - Captain Boomerang
Flarrow Teaser
Here’s details on what’s going on with
that.
Captain Boomerang is the villain of the crossover
episodes.
They’re going with his Suicide Squad backstory.
In the comics the character was formerly part
of the Suicide Squad but he’s Flash villain.
So he fits into both shows really nicely.
Everyone from Team Arrow will go to Central
City in the first part of the crossover on
The Flash to get info on him.
Then in part 2 Team Flash will come to Starling
City to help Team Arrow take him down.
I don’t want to post more info than necessary
but there’s a whole lot more
going on with those episodes.
So be sure to watch them.
They’re Episode 8 on both shows.
Arrow is one episode ahead right now but they’ll
take a week off next week so flash can catch
up.
And they just announced that Arrow and Flash
would do another two part crossover in the
second half of
the season.
They just started planning it, so no info
on what
the story will be.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment and here’s my big question for you
guys.
How badly do you want to punch Thea’s douchbag
DJ in the face.
He can be Roy’s new training dummy